مشروع سقف الدين يعبر اختباره الثاني
بالتصويت عليه في مجلس النواب وخلال
النقاش حول التشريع تبادلت الديمقراطيون
والجمهوريون التهمه بالتسبب بازمه سقف
الدين
منذ البدايه كان الديمقراطيون واضحين اننا
لن نسمح للجمهوريين من الماجا بالتخلف عن
سداد ديوننا او تحطيم الاقتصاد او التسبب
بركود يقتل الوظائف طيب
انه فيما نعالج المشكله التي تسبب بها
الرئيس بايدن عبر انفاق اموال ليست لدينا
لسنوات ان نبدا في حلها
لكن رغم معارضه جمهوريين يمينيين
وديمقراطيين كان التفاؤل سيد الموقف حيث
عبر رئيس المجلس كابل مكار في عن ثقته
بتمرير التشريع
الليله ستكون مختلفه الليله سنقوم بشيء لم
نقم به من قبل سنمنح امريكا الامل
الجمهوريون مرروا قبل ذلك قاعده تحكم
النقاش حول التشريع ما هذا الطريق لمروره
النهائي حيث قدمت ديمقراطيون مساعدتهم
بعدما صوت ضده 29 جمهوريا
تم تمرير المشروع في مجلس الشيوخ ستبقى
الخطوه الاخيره توقيع الرئيس عليه ليصبح
قنونا حسين الطوض العربيه واشنطن لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات